foreign
Albany hi Eric welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thank you sir appreciate your taking my
taking my question sure what's up
so
I I I
keep getting into my head and wanting to
liquidate all my investments and pay off
my mortgage
um
and I I kind of know that like
mathematically that's probably not the
right choice but like I feel like it
would be a major pressure reliever and
then to be able to go back through and
just use all my description and cash
stuff
start going back in and rebuilding my
portfolio
so how much do you have in uh your
uh I have my stock portfolio I have what
is uh
hundred and eighty thousand dollars
did you say 180 or did you say 80.
180 000 okay and what's your mortgage
balance
my mortgage balance is like 170. okay
all right and those are the the
portfolio you're discussing is not in a
retirement account correct yeah it's a
taxable account yeah okay and your
debt-free other than your home
yeah for the most part I have I have a
credit card that's got a very low
balance on it that I've literally just
charged last month that it paid off by
the other month okay
and what's your household income
uh free tax about 260. good for you well
done how old are you
I'm 40. okay
and so uh so you're saying that
mathematically it doesn't make sense and
I would even challenge that part I think
mathematically it does make sense to pay
off your house
um well we bought we bought my house in
2012 and
um we we got we got like three and a
half percent interest on it so at this
point we've overpaid on it ever since
and paid bi-weekly yeah and so at this
point I'm like not really paying any any
interest on it and what interest and
pain is minimal
um versus the returns that I've been
able to get in the stock market
um you know but you've not factored in
Risk
right there's no math for risk in your
formula
and not factoring in Risk mathematically
is a naive formula
um and um so here's what we know we know
from the data of studying millionaires
that the typical millionaire does two
things that causes them to get to their
first one to five million dollars that
they get out of debt house and
everything and they build their 401K in
the Roth IRAs and good growth stock
mutual funds the number of millionaires
that we asked that said and we said okay
did you
leverage your home in order to invest in
stocks and that's why you became a
millionaire the number of them that say
that is very close to zero
they say stuff like well Lord no I got
out of debt
isn't that interesting
so the formula that you're proposing is
mathematically correct
um is not used by hardly any
millionaires to get to millionaire
status
Translation your formula is wrong
so Eric would you take out against your
home a hundred eighty thousand dollar
loan to invest into single stocks
but
um
well I think it's you know if if that
what I was doing for for a living yeah
sure why not but if you were day trading
for a living basically
yeah
um you also probably wouldn't be
sleeping at night you'd lose
relationships because you'd be staring
at these numbers making sure they go up
all the time you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right about that so
there's a piece of this where man I can
feel it you're craving that peace but
you're stuck on the Starry Eyed but what
if I got this return on that money and
the guaranteed return in your house I
think is way more valuable so here's
what I would do you called us and so uh
really really simply I would cash out
the stock and pay off the house today
now then I don't have a house payment I
have an increased
stability
at the very Foundation of my life and my
financial plan because I you you cannot
grasp and you actually can't
mathematically capture that it feels
different to walk through your backyard
with no shoes on the grass feels
different when you don't have a mortgage
you cannot capture that you cannot
capture what this does that the stress
release even if it's minor what that
does for your relationships you cannot
capture what it does for your boldness
and Your Excellence in your career and
all of those things over time the math
actually plays out
to that people of means people of wealth
actually do not take out home mortgages
to trade themselves buy and sell single
stocks those are called day Traders 78
of which lose money and um lose a lot of
other things while they're doing it so
George want to hear about the ones that
win well and you'll and they're always
temporary because you know it's the same
thing as playing the slots oh I wanted
the slots right yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's how they built those certain
casinos okay not by you winning at the
slots I can tell you that so
mathematically just because you hit it
once doesn't mean you're gonna so all
that to say Eric I'm going off the data
of the 30 years of doing what I do
walking alongside people watching their
lives transform watching their
relationships their careers Blossom uh
and their portfolio because when you
don't have a house payment and you make
260 000 a year you can build up 180 000
bucks really quick if you want to screw
around single stocks won't take long at
all so good question thank you for
calling pay off your house today sir
yeah the whole end goal of both of our
discussions is build wealth the question
is what is the best path to do it and we
have found that doing it with the least
amount of risk possible puts you in a
better financial position long term and
so what we're saying here is you're
going to build wealth either way you
could lose your butt hanging on to these
single stocks in the next week depending
on who tweets what or you could have a
guaranteed return with no house payment
making 260 thousand dollars you think
you can build wealth with that situation
absolutely a hundred percent of the time
you can so uh and a hundred percent of
the foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage so
didn't have to do a lot of research on
that it'll come to you later I promise
uh so that's the idea folks that's the
idea what is your most powerful wealth
building tool
is it your home equity nope
it's your income
person in your mirror is the secret
sauce
for you to build wealth for you to build
a quality life
you're the secret sauce you're the
answer no one's going to do it for you
and there is no magic pill that you've
yet to discover
go go in there
brush the fog off of the mirror after
the shower and look at that guy look at
that gal and go you're the problem
you're the solution